♪♪
>> AMERICA'S WORST MAYOR WANTS
YOU TO THINK SHE'S DOING A GREAT
JOB.
NO, WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT HER
KARAOKE SKILLS.
CHICAGO'S LORI LIGHTFOOT THINKS
SHE DESERVES ANOTHER SHOT AT
RUNNING THE WINDY CITY, BOASTING
ABOUT HER HANDLING OF CRIME.
>> YOU WOULDN'T KNOW IT BY
WATCHING THE NEWS, LISTENING TO
THE HATERS, BUT ON CRIME MAYOR
LIGHTFOOT HAS A PLAN.
SHE'S PUTTING MORE POLICE ON THE
STREETS, GETTING MORE GUNS OFFER
THEM.
WHEN IT COMES TO NEW STRATEGIES,
NEW TECHNOLOGY, LIGHTFOOT HAS
INVESTED MORE THAN ANY MAYOR.
THOSE ARE FACTS.
>> SPEAKING OF FACTS, HERE'S A
FEW.
MURDERS ARE NEARLY 40% HIGHER
THAN IN 2019 WHEN LIGHTFOOT
FIRST TOOK OFFICE, AND LIGHTFOOT
IS SO DESPERATE TO GET
RE-ELECTED, SHE'S BRIBING
CHILDREN TO BOOST HER CAMPAIGN.
CHICAGO PUBLIC SCHOOL INSPECTOR
GENERAL HAS REPORTEDLY OPENED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO EMAILS FROM
HER CAMPAIGN ASKING TEACHERS TO
ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO VOLUNTEER
IN EXCHANGE FOR SCHOOL CREDIT.
I MEAN, IF I'M GETTING SCHOOL
CREDIT, I CAMPAIGN FOR ANYBODY,
GREG.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
WHY DIDN'T I THINK OF THIS?
IF YOU COULD SUPPLY ME WITH
TALKING POINTS, STUDENTS, THAT'S
EXTRA CREDIT.
LOOK, IMAGINE IF SHE WENT AFTER
GANGS THE WAY SHE WENT AFTER
THAT LIMO COMPANY.
REMEMBER, THEY LEFT THAT YELP
REVIEW.
SHE'S THE ONLY MAYOR OF A CITY
THAT'S COMPLETELY OVERRUN BY
CARTELS.
I MEAN, THEY RUN THAT CITY.
SHE'S NOT FIGHTING CRIME.
SHE'S FIGHTING FOR POWER.
OTHER PEOPLE SUFFERING ONLY
CROSSES HER RADAR ONCE IT POSES
A POLITICAL THREAT.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
REPUBLICANS TEND TO CONFRONT
THEIR PROBLEM CHILDREN, BE IT
SANTOS OR SOMEBODY ELSE.
THE DEMS JUST ELECT THEM TO BE A
HISTORICAL FIRST.
YEAH, SHE'S THE FIRST MAYOR TO
BE UNDER THE THUMB OF CARTELS.
SHE'S THE WORST MAYOR IN
AMERICA.
THE WORST MAYOR CHICAGO HAS EVER
HAD.
LOOKS LIKE SHE HASN'T DRESSED
SINCE 1983.
DRESSES LIKE THEY PANTSED THE
SALVATION ARMY BELL RINGER.
SHE'S A BLACK LESBIAN LEFT
WINGER.
THEY'RE WILLING TO LET THE CITY
BE RUN INTO THE GROUND.
A 40% INCREASE IN MURDER.
NO WHITE GUY COULD GET AWAY WITH
THAT.
>> HMM.
THAT'S A BAD TRACK RECORD TO RUN
ON.
IS ANYBODY RUNNING AGAINST MAYOR
LIGHTFOOT?
>> ONE OF THE THINGS I WROTE
DOWN IN THE BREAK, GOING TO
THIS, SADLY I THINK NOTHING IS
GOING TO CHANGE THERE.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> THINK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN
PHILADELPHIA, WHEN THEY HAD A
RECALL OPPORTUNITY TO RECALL
THAT GUY KRASNER, AND HE JUST
GOT RE-ELECTED, THE SAME THING
HAPPENED OUT IN CALIFORNIA WITH
WATCH MA CALL IT THERE.
GASCON.
IT'S LIKE WHEN BIDEN SAYS IT'S
THE BIGGEST DROP IN GAS PRICES
IN HISTORY.
ONLY BECAUSE IT WENT UP SO MUCH
UNDER YOUR WATCH.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
YESTERDAY WE FOUND OUT THAT
YOUNG ADULT MALES FROM ZIP CODES
WITH THE MOST VIOLENT IN CHICAGO
AND PHILLY HAD A NOTABLY HIGHER
RISK OF FIREARM-RELATED DEATH
THAN U.S. MILITARY SERVE NOTHING
ALL THE YEARS IN IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN.
THAT'S THE AD I WOULD RUN THERE.
>> YOU GOT TO GO TO WAR TO BE
SAFE.
THAT'S CRAZY.
GERALDO, HOW DANGEROUS IS
CHICAGO?
>> BUILT A TRIP AROUND A WEDDING
THERE IN DECEMBER.
CHICAGO HAS ALWAYS BEEN A TALE
OF TWO CITIES.
SOUTH SIDE AND NORTHSIDE.
SOUTH SIDE, OVERWHELMING BLACK
AND POOR HALF OF THE CITY IS
WHERE MOST OF THE GANG VIOLENCE
IS HAPPENING.
CHICAGO IS ON TRACK NOW TO HAVE
OVER -- OR HAD OVER 700 MURDERS
AND LED THE NATION BY FAR IN
MURDERS LAST YEAR.
SHE RUNS ON A VERY TENUOUS
RECORD.
THE PROBLEM FROM HER POINT OF
VIEW POLITICALLY IS THAT NOW
THAT FEAR OF CRIME, THAT
ABSOLUTE TERROR HAS PEOPLE ON
THE NORTH SIDE OF TOWN, THE MORE
AFFLUENT SIDE OF TOWN, GETTING
PRIVATE POLICE FORCES, SECURITY
GUARDS.
SO THE WHOLE TEMPO OF LIFE IN
THE WINDY CITY HAS BEEN
UNDERMINED.
WILL SHE BE RE-ELECTED?
USING KIDS?
IT'S A BRILLIANT IDEA TO USE
KIDS.
IT'S A SCAM.
THERE'S AN INHERENT DISHONESTY
TO IT.
YET YOU COULD PAINT IT, WHAT A
GREAT PROGRAM, GET THE KIDS
INVOLVED IN POLITICS, MUNICIPAL
GOVERNMENT AND SO FORTH.
CHICAGO IS IN A TERRIBLE PLACE.
I THINK GREG IS RIGHT, SHE'LL BE
RE-ELECTED, AND NOTHING YOU CAN
DO ABOUT IT.
>> SHOULD ONLY MAKE OUR SHOES
AND PHONES.
>> MAKE OUR SHOES TOO?
>> YOU KNOW HOW HARD TO FIND A
COMPANY TO MAKE A SHOE WITHOUT
USING CHILD LABOR?
I HAVE A REAL PROBLEM WITH THIS.
I MEAN, FIRST OF ALL, IF THIS
WAS A REPUBLICAN OR A
LIBERTARIAN MAYOR WHO DID THE
SAME THING, THEY WOULD HAVE SAID
HELL NO.
THEY'RE RATTING HER OUT.
SHE STOOD UP TO THE TEACHERS
UNION, WHEN THEY WANTED TO KEEP
THE SCHOOLS CLOSED.
THAT'S ONE GOOD THING SHE DID.
>> NOT A LITTLE THING.
>> NO.
BUT THIS CHILD LABOR, GRADES
HAVE TANKED SO MUCH IN THE
HARDEST-HIT SCHOOLS IN CHICAGO
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC, THAT
THEY HAVE TO DO WHATEVER THEY
CAN TO GIVE THEM CREDIT TO BOOST
THEIR GPAs SO THEY HAVE A
SNOWBALL'S CHANCE IN HELL OF
GETTING INTO COLLEGES.
>> SO THERE'S GOING DO BE MIDDLE
SCHOOLERS WITH A LITTLE PLACARD
THAT SAYS, GO LORI, FREEZING ON
THE SOUTH SIDE OF CHICAGO FOR
SCHOOL CREDIT.
>> BUT MAKE IT BULLET-PROOF.
KIDS ARE OUT THERE, YOU GOT TO
KEEP THEM SAFE.
>> IF ONE KID GETS H